get more on Russia's decision to
withdraw from the grain deal Russell
said its life for us in Istanbul and
wrestle of course turkey played such a
big role in brokering the original grain
deal last year what does it make of this
decision by Russia given that turkey was
one of the many beneficiaries of the
deal
indeed so president erdogan today is
starting his golf tour which is
including Saudi Arabia Qatar and United
Arab Emirates and today is just now
about to fly to the city of Jeddah in
Saudi Arabia at the airport before his
flight he made his first statement
regarding this the the the suspension of
the grain deal and he said that my
friend Putin I believe that he wants to
continue this humanitarian Corridor
through the Black Sea and he says that
after my tour in golf once I am back in
the country I am going to resume the
talks with the Russian with the Russian
officials and the the President Putin as
well however he didn't elaborate on that
we do not know what is going to be the
plan that is going to be developed by
turkey so far but we know that there has
been tremendous diplomatic affords right
ahead of this day there has been several
talks between the diplomats several
phone calls and and meetings and so on
however that all diplomatic efforts have
failed so far turkey was one of the main
beneficiary of that politically and
economically as well because roughly so
far there's been more than 32 million
tons of the Ukrainian grain that went to
the international market and turkey
received roughly around 3.2 million of
that politically turkey being one of the
deal broker here being a mediator also
was giving it a Prestige and also being
an actor in all of this equation now
they're all in danger and right behind
me you can see that there are still
several ships that are anchoring here
and many of them are having the Iran
Ukrainian grain and expecting to be
inspected here once they're inspected
they will go through the Bose forest and
that grain is going to be exported to
the the to the global market but from
today on probably we are going to see
less and less ships anchoring right
behind me and Russell what does this
decision by Moscow say about Turkish
influence over Russia I mean is the
perception that uh the Turkish president
has been perhaps drifting West in his
alliances recently particularly over
NATO
well Turkish officials the reactions or
the talks that I have with some of the
officials here they believe that it is
not related to the the suspension of the
deal is not related to the recent
developments but rather the attack in
the church bridge in or or criminal
Crimea breach and but on the other hand
we know that recently when uh president
zelenski of Ukraine was Western turkey
turkey has given him six uh a senior as
of commanders and Russia was Furious
about that because they said that turkey
has violated the agreement and according
to the agreement that commanders were
supposed to remain to stay in Turkey
till the war is concluded and also
president erdon has clearly announced
his support for Ukraine's membership to
to Nato and just two days after that
when President erdogan attended the NATO
Summit in Vilnius in Lithuania he has
also given green light to Sweden's
accession to Nato all of these
developments definitely were not
welcomed by Russia however the analysts
the experts here are saying that after
the election President erdogan's and
turkey's direction is going to be lean
toward the west and a little bit
distancing itself from the Moscow but as
of now it's not a rupture Turkish
Russian relations are quite
multi-layered and very much
sophisticated for both parties there's a
lot at the stake and I think both sides
are acting very much carefully not to
broke these ties a lot at stake at the
wrestle soda in Istanbul thank you
so when the grain deal was first
announced a year ago it's quoted purpose
was to contribute to the prevention of
global hunger and to reduce and address
Global Food insecurity so just where
have all the shipments gone well U.N
figures show that developing nations
received almost 60 percent of the almost
33 million tons of exports a closer look
at the data shows 25 percent went to
China
43 percent of experts exports were
shipped to what the UN calls High income
countries so Spain Italy the Netherlands
and Israel were the top recipients
low-income countries that rely on
assistance from the world food program
accounted for just two and a half
percent of Ukrainian exports and they
included Ethiopia and Yemen receiving
just 10 percent of what China imported